This is the Chris Abraham show.
God grant me the serenity to
accept the things.
I cannot change the courage to
change the things I can, and the
wisdom to know the difference.
Living one day, at a time,
enjoying one moment at a time.
Taking this world as it is and
not as I would have it trusting
that you will make all things
right?
If I surrender to your will.
So that I may be reasonably
happy in this life and supremely
happy with you forever in the
next, amen.
Tender and compassionate God,
you are our steadfast companion
in the joyous times of Our
Lives.
When we Rejoice, you celebrate
with us.
When we are anxious and Afraid.
You offer us a relationship
where we can find courage to
face the unknown.
When we weep with sadness, you
are our comforter help us o God
to believe that you receive us
as we are.
ER and help us to entrust
ourselves with all our many
struggles and hopes to your
faithful in abiding care.
Amen.
May the gentleness of God
supportive and sustaining love
gather Us in her arms, this day
and bless us with sleep.
That restores both Body and
Soul.
Amen.
Facing the future, every Journey
Begins With, but a small step
and every day is a chance for a
new small step in the right
direction.
Just follow your heart song.
Lord Almighty grant us a
peaceful night and a perfect
End.
Amen.
Guide us waking O Lord and guard
us sleeping that awake.
We may watch with Christ and
asleep.
We may rest in peace.
Keep watch dear Lord with those
who work or watch or weep this
night and give your angels
charge over those who sleep.
Tend the sick, Lord Christ, give
rest to the weary bless the
dying, soothe the suffering,
pity The Afflicted Shield, the
joyous and all for your love
sake, amen, goddess, waking O,
Lord, and guard asleep.
Beeping that awake we may watch
with Christ and asleep.
We may rest in peace.
Lord you now have set your
servant free to go in peace.
As you have promised for these
eyes of mine have seen the
Savior whom you have prepared
for all the world to see a light
to Enlighten the nation's and
the glory of your People Israel.
Glory to the father and to the
son and to the Holy Spirit as it
was in the beginning is now and
will be forever.
Amen.
Goddess waking a Lord and guard
is sleeping that awake.
We may watch with Christ and
asleep.
We may rest in peace.
Be sober, Be watchful your
adversary, the devil prowls
around, like a roaring lion,
seeking someone to devour resist
him firm in your faith.
Come to me all who labor and are
heavy laden and I will give you
rest.
Take my yoke upon you and learn
from me for.
I am gentle and lowly in heart
and you will find rest for your
souls.
For my yoke is easy and my
burden is light.
The Lord Almighty grant us a
peaceful night in a perfect End.
Amen.
Our help is in the name of the
Lord, the maker of heaven and
Earth.
Let us confess our sins to God
almighty God.
Our heavenly father, we have
sinned against you through our
own fault, in thought and word
and deed, and in what we have
left undone for the sake of your
son.
Our Lord Jesus Christ, forgive
us, all our offenses.
And Grant that we may serve you
and newness of life to the glory
of your name.
Amen.
Thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham show.
Make sure you subscribe.
So you don't miss any future
episodes until next time.